اعتبر وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
عدم تحرير شبه جزيره القرم يعني ان اي
حديث عن الامن الاقليمي ليس اكثر من وهم
وقال رزني كوفا في تصريحات صحفيه ان الوقت
مهم بالنسبه وان تجميد الحرب سيؤدي الى
وقف تقدم المنطقه باسرها
بدون تحرير شبه جزيره القرم فان اي حديث
عن الامن الاقليمي ليس اكثر من وهم
استعاده القرم ستضمن السلامه الكامله
وحريه الملاحه في البحر الاسود وبحر ازوف
ستعود القرن الى العائله الاوكرانيه كما
كانت عام واحد وتسعين سنفعل كل ما هو
ضروري لعودتها يجب ان نعترف بصدق ان تحقيق
السلام المستدام والمتطلبات الاساسيه
للازدهار المشترك في المنطقه امر مستحيل
بدون التغيير في روسيا الوقت مهم وتجميد
الحرب سيعني عدم تقدم المنطقه باسرها
وسيؤدي الى فرص ضائعه